here is Chris Sale who feels like he's
getting better and better and better and
it was a baby step in game one for Chris
Sale although he lasted just two and two
thirds all right Jose Altuve digging in
and he flies one into left here got
under it it carries to the track for out
number one
same way we started last night Bradley
now 2-2 pitch struck him out of
96. two down gregman now who homered
with two out nobody on the first inning
in game four Camden long throw Bogarts
wow
made that look easy in a one two three
first from bur Valdez how do you build a
momentum well your next day starter is
the way you build on it or the way you
lose it and they're going to need a
better output out of cranberry Valdez
and his Sinker is going to be the key PK
went Deep Off Valdez in game one
[Applause]
borderline pitch and Valdez gets the
call one away it was a good pitch for
out number one and Kyle schwarber will
stand in
broken back ground ball that's Correa
two out Xander Bogarts will walk in
here's a no one ground ball to short
Correa gathers and throws in a 1-2-3
inning each side Alvarez is five for 14
in the ALCS hitting 357 does not have an
extra base hit yet in this series and
Alvarez hits it well and hits it deep to
left field and you can kiss that one
goodbye into the monster seats for
yardan and it's one nothing Astros boy
is shot the other way for Alvarez big
number 44 puts the Astros on top and
opposite field blast second home run of
the postseason for Alvarez and just the
second extra base hit that's Chris Sale
has allowed to a left-handed hitter all
year here is
Oh What A Catch down there forget me out
I mean I know this is an ALCS out but
that guy this back goes a long ways and
could be dangerous watch this catch oh
wow how good is that that is amazing
a lot of people thanking him and they
should that is a weapon heading into the
seats
JD Martinez didn't have a hit last night
but he reached with his first inning
walk he's now reached in 15 straight
postseason games
instead he Strikes Out 2-2
curveball drops in for strike three
Renfro Frozen and the inning is over
three strikeouts for fromber starting
pitchers for Houston a total of six and
two-thirds Innings pitched this would be
something that hasn't been done if
Valdez can get through this Frame
one-two pitch is grounded to First Fair
ball guriel to the bag one up
left side bregman
two down with the bases empty Vasquez is
walking in here's a 1-2 Vasquez strike
from bervaldez in total control so far
two three four hitters for Houston
leading by a run
told him struck him out out number one
to Fourth Correa up in a key spot here
for the Astros who already lead one to
nothing
struck him out two out big big strikeout
for sale in the Red Sox first and third
two out brings in Kyle Tucker he fires
swing and a messy got him on a High
Rider at 98. and sale does a little
dance as he leaves the mound the Red Sox
slimy a threat after three and a half
still one-nothing Houston
strikes in the second inning
this is a ground ball that's Deborah's
that is fantastic near the bag as he
charged and made a perfect throw one out
this Jose Siri shoots one into left
center field and [ __ ] Hernandez to his
right to out
with two out nobody on Maldonado will
step to the plate no one delivery
the pop-up right side
long run but there's
one here's Devers Red Sox are saying
let's see what he's like out of the
stretch
[Applause]
man is on for Boston to the fifth Valdez
induced 11 ground ball double plays
during the regular season that was tied
for second most on the Astros Hunter
Renfro struck out his first time might
be two Correa flips out over to first
got them both and that is what Valdez
gets ground balls and he turns this one
into a twin killing two out bevers comes
halfway almost ground ball right side
curiel to the bag and what a job by
fromber Valdez lead off one puts out to
the aboard Runner goes and a little
ground ball to the third baseman Dippers
safe at first going first to third is
Altuve it's first and third nobody out
in the Astros with a golden chance to
add to their lead here in the six that
are now pregnant and another clunker
sale looks Altuve back and gets he out
at first down to second is Brantley one
away it's second and third one out and
the batteries you're down Alvarez and
that one's down the line into left what
a night Alvarez has delivered again two
more runs will score off his back he's
driven in all three and it's three
nothing Astros here in the sixth first
and third two out three yellow for two
base hit might score two
as Renfro gets it back in it's four
nothing Astros on top here's a chance to
blow It Wide Open the batter is Siri
looking for his first hit second and
third two down here's a 1-2 little Fly
ball into right that will drop for a hit
one run scores Here Comes guriel throw
is cut off and it's six nothing Houston
here in the sixth into the bottom of the
sixth of game five with a bottom two in
the order coming up one and two the
count the next swing and a miss struck
him out strikeout number five for Valdez
back to the top of the order and [ __ ]
Hernandez under its second Hernandez
Skies one into right easy for Tucker
[Applause]
two down 1-1 pitch
that's caught by guriel the inning is
over down to second is Altuve with
nobody out and still no pitches to
Bramley
and a little flare into Center Fields
gonna drop for a base hit Altuve was off
with a crack of the bat and he scores to
make it seven to nothing on an RBI by
Michael Brantley the Red Sox are going
to win this game they have to score in
this inning they've got to crack that
lead and get some kind of momentum and
get into the bullpen
is the delivery driven deep to right
down by the pesky Paul and it is gone a
home run for Rafi Demers his fifth this
postseason the eighth of his career and
the Red Sox are on the board 7-1 Houston
he is the crowd something the chair as
rapid hit off screaming line drive fair
by maybe 10 feet 1-2
[Music]
second turn tonight Robert Valdez back
to work 1-2 pitch now ground ball right
into the teeth of the defense altube
gets the out Arroyo shoot two pitch on
the way and uh Fly ball into right right
at Tucker
two down a two-strike pitch
and that's lifted in the year to left it
backs up Brantley onto the track in
front of the monster makes the catch a
step shy of that wall and it's a one two
three inning for fronter Valdez eight
Innings of one run ball for the Astros
Lefty very dangerous hitter a man who's
got 62 career postseason hits
all five of these lcs's he gets a base
hit into Center to score two more
bregman scores Correa scores and it's
nine to one here in the ninth inning
Michelob Ultra organic Seltzer as real
as it tastes